aux etats unis maintenant joe biden a
signé hier la loi du budget militaire
une somme finalement supérieur à ce
qu'avait proposé le locataire de la
maison blanche et qui conforte le pays
comme le plus dépensier du monde dans ce
domaine bien loin devant les autres on
retrouve justement thomas bowness notre
correspondant à washington
thomas bonsoir alors comment expliquer
cette augmentation du budget militaire
américain
est bien officiellement les états unis
ne veulent pas se faire distancer par
leurs rivaux sur la scène internationale
et veulent être en capacité de faire
face aux différentes menaces voilà pour
le discours officiel qu'on entend chez
certains parlementaires pour justifier
ce budget pour l'année 2022 qui s'élève
à 768 milliards de dollars c'est
quasiment un record c'est en tout cas
plus que lorsque les états unis ont mené
les guerres en corée ou au vietnam en
fait la seule année où ce budget était
plus élevée c'était en 2011 lorsque les
troupes américaines étaient
particulièrement nombreuse être déployé
en irak et en afghanistan alors ce
budget prévoir un certain nombre de
réformes structurelles de l'achat de
matériel mais aussi des programmes de
soutien à stratégie pour les états unis
programme de soutien à taiwan ou encore
à l'ukraine 300 millions de dollars sont
prévus pour entraîner et équiper l'armée
ukrainienne ce budget total est en
hausse de 5% par rapport à l'année
dernière il est même plus élevé que ce
qu'avait initialement préconisé joe
biden un budget qui est donc en hausse
malgré le retrait des troupes
américaines d'afghanistan et lors de
cette annonce de ce retrait à venir au
printemps dernier une parlementaire
démocrate avait alerté joe biden pour
lui demander à d'allouer les économies
réalisées par ce retrait des troupes
pour des problématiques plus nationale
écoutez un extrait de cette lettre
qu'elle avait donc adressé au président
américain
les estimations indiquent que 50
milliards de dollars seront économisés
avec le retrait des troupes
d'afghanistan
réallouer cette somme aux priorités
nationales et aux besoins humains
pourraient étendre votre plan de relance
cela pourrait mettre un terme à la
situation des sans abri aux états unis
être en place une couverture médicale
aux américains dans le besoin ou même
contribuer à la lutte contre la pandémie
de covile 19
mai finalement malgré le retrait des
troupes américaines d'afghanistan aucune
coupe budgétaire pour eux ce qui
concerne l'armée américaine avec 768
milliards de dollars de budgets alloués
à ce secteur les etats unis restent très
loin devant les autres pays du monde
l'an dernier déjà washington dépenser à
elle seule plus que l'ensemble des onze
autres pays qui la suivent dans ce
classement des dépenses militaires des
pays tels que la chine la russie encore
le royaume uni un écart qui n'est donc
pas près de se resserrer avec ce nouveau
budget signé cette semaine par joe biden
merci beaucoup thomas bonnin en direct
de washington